everyone my name is pavel and welcome to
the talk about
how to design a good api what to look
into specific
so
few words about me i'm a programmer
since more or less nine years
commercially i was working at
well first telecom then logistics
industry then i think banking car
factory and currently in a polish
software house previous software
and indirectly say in a travel industry
for a client
so the agenda of this talk will look
more or less like an rpg party who of
you likes roleplaying games
there are some people okay cool
so first
we'll look at things from
let's say distant perspective to looks
look what's what's going on in general
and then we will be looking from the
perspective of three wizards from the
ivory tower so just a little bit theory
to to give you some insights
and some bases
then we'll get to business so there will
be this this dwarf who is hacking orcs
and goblins and doing the action is
doing the actual business job
uh what we get money from and behind
this
dwarf there is usually the cleric who is
buffing him and hitting him and
there will be talking about things that
are that are kind kind of orthogonal to
this business perspective but
nevertheless important
so let's begin
there was a guy in the marketing by the
name of simon sinek and he wrote a book
start with why and indeed when we are
going on some kind of business or
otherwise adventure we need to think
about three questions
why are we doing something what are we
actually doing and how to do this so the
most important question is why so let's
look into that
why the answer is of course simple for
money
so basically how how do we earn money on
web applications there was usually in
the past there was some kind of front
end
business logic probably database users
were clicking doing some stuff they need
to and we earn on that
as time passes user
needs of users grow so they require
additional features and it didn't really
make sense to do all those features in
our system for example if you are
it's a travel company and you want to
display a map it's not the best idea to
just jump into the car start driving
around the city and doing pictures of
of stuff so that people can see this on
our website it's better idea to connect
to some api for example google maps
so
as time passes further our system grew
larger
more valuable especially our data were
more precious so it's good idea to open
an additional revenue stream and create
an external api so that someone else can
connect to us use our data and pay us
for that
so that's what we'll be more or less
talking about today so an external web
api what is this well it's kind of
simple it's just a set of end points
with which we can
talk using a specified set of messages
requests and responses
and how to do this well that would be
the objective of the talk but uh in
general there is an observation that
although we are talking about machine
talking to the machine
there are people behind those machines
of developers programmers
and web api is kind of like
graphical user interface to the
programmer it's like user interface to
the programmer similarly as graphical
user interface is to regular people who
just click stuff on the web
so there was
a lot of
things were said uh in the realm of how
to design a good graphical user
interface and we can actually leverage
some of that knowledge in designing web
api
so the
two
important traits of people is let's say
laziness and intuition so we are all
lazy we want to do stuff
as easy as possible and as fast as
possible and we have intuition so we
have some
idea how stuff works some standards so
experiences
and if we confront to that
well it's it will be good for us in
general
so that was a quick introduction then
free wizards
so just a little bit of theory
uh who recognizes peter morviel
nobody
oh there is one person cool so
the guy from design basically and he
wrote an article
10 years ago or so maybe even a bit more
where he pointed out the six important
traits of good product design
so those traits are in general that
product should be useful so we should be
able to do the the business stuff that
we want to to do
the reason for for which we bought the
product in the first place
it should be usable so it should be easy
to do this it should be intuitive
it should be desirable so
you are happy with the product for
example if you are developers acting on
an api the api has a nice documentation
and always works and
well
we desire this let's say
it should be findable so
it should be easy to find the stuff that
we want to do for example api is not
buried under some
a lot of slashes and long urls it's
somewhere close to the top domain of of
the
of the company its own slot
uh it should be
accessible originally in the article it
was about the products used by people
with some kind of disability for example
let's say blind people it's nice
is a product then talks to them or it's
possible to
touch the product and for example read
braille characters uh in case of api an
example would be
we are disabled because we are sitting
behind a proxy that only grants
only oppresses the
get requests and we want to do a post
request or put request and how to deal
with that i will be talking about this
later
and
and it should be credible meaning well
every product should be credible it
shouldn't break but if it breaks
the
the producer of the product shouldn't
leave us alone with that so in case of
api you know of course sometimes stuff
breaks we get 500 from the server but
it's also nice if if the
api provider gives us more information
about how to deal with this problem and
that would be another chapter in our
story
the second wizard roy fielding anyone
familiar with roy fielding
okay there are some people
anyone actually read the fielding phd
dissertation
okay oh nice
uh so refuelling this is a guy who's
who's involved in the
i'd say
standardization of http and uri
and in 2000 he wrote a ph.d 13 defended
phd dissertations
where he defined the rest architecture
so basically
if someone asks you what is actually
rest because we heard this a lot of time
but
if we
think a bit deeper about what it is so
it's not a protocol it's not technology
it's not not really a standard it's an
architectural style
and it was
basically the thesis is about
properties how we can assess web
architectures there are several web
architectures in the assessment and then
there is this rest so representational
state transfer
and what's the idea
there are those
six principles
first client server so we have separate
client and server originally it was more
of a
front end and back end but it's not
really the case anymore so we can
develop them independently
we have statelessness so
basically each request has enough
information to be processed without
storing some kind of inside state
because if the machine dies then we lose
the state we can send the request to
another machine and if we have
everything with the request that we need
to do we are good
but there comes a problem we need to
send more data so there is a principle
of cachability so every response and
from the server
basically tell us on what condition we
can store it and to use later
so then we can save a bit on bandwidth
and computing power on both sides
basically
uh layered system is about
that we can in let's say inject some
kind of layer between client and server
and it should be basically
transparent to the client
inform interfaces
more or less about that
our addresses our naming schemes should
be consistent and we should use http
semantics so
methods
status codes and standard headers
and code of demand is that's an optional
requirement but the idea is that we can
from the server we can send some
executable code that can be invoked by
the client and those extend
its capabilities
so that's briefly about rest
learner t-shirts on anyone
yep
so just quickly oh no richardson i
created
i think 20 or 10 years ago or so on the
qcon talk he defined the levels of how
restful the architecture is and just the
results of model
you might have heard and the idea is
that well at the level zero
we have this swamp of plain old xml so
we have and one endpoint to which we
sent on xml file which basically says
what has to be done
then the level two is resources so
entities in our system
have different endpoints and
if we have people cars groups or
whatever they have separate endpoints
and we can work on that
the next level is usage of http verbs so
no longer we have to wonder
should i invoke delete cars or maybe
remove cars i don't know we just go to
cars and use the delete method
and the last level is hyper media
control
also known as haitos this beautiful
acronym in our
i.t
so basically we add links to our
responses that can lead us to related
resources
okay those were
those those was a bit of theory now
practice so
the business stuff
about we talk about resources naming
relations between resources
the behavior of particular http methods
depending whether we have collection or
single objects
about functions because you know rest is
about nouns so how to deal with
functions then
how to parameterize requests so that we
can operate efficiently on collections
and how to handle status and as it
sometimes happens errors
so quickly resources the centric focus
point of rest nouns plural forms so that
we have cars which is a collection of
cars and we can have cars slash id which
is a particular car
uh
it's good to remember about not sharing
technical details in url so for example
if you have apache server that's great
but do not put it in the url just keep
it clean and simple as possible
about naming
there was this ancient war between camel
case and snake case
and actually now we have
a
kind of a bit popular new style hyphen
case also known as kebab case because
you have like this piece of meat on the
stick then you have wars with high pens
and basically the old war was between
commerce and snake you know camel people
from javascript say hey we have json we
like json so json is javascript so camel
case makes sense on the other hand hand
snake case well they say it's a bit more
readable because words are a bit far
apart from each other looks better
hyphen case actually there's one problem
with hyphen case because if you
run this through some automatic
automating frameworks that matches the
name of property with the objects or the
the object itself then you can run to
the problem that there is a minus sign
basically and that's a operator in
programming language so it looks cool
in a content that is consumable by
people like you have a blog you have new
article there's a few words in the title
so your wordpress generates a nice link
with hyphens in between and it looks
good but in api
maybe not the best idea
personally i think i prefer camo case
because i'm from java but yeah anyway
whichever you choose just try to stay
consistent not like
some standard libraries for some
languages that makes cases
not the best idea so we have resources
now we have relations between those
resources
so how to model that
basically if the resource resources are
independent they can exist
independently for example we have people
and we have groups well people can live
without groups groups can formally be
without people
then group membership is another
resource so basically it can be created
deleted or manipulated
on the other hand if we have resource
that depends on another
say we have a building and room in a
building if the building collapses then
the room is probably not too good either
in this case we can model that
in this character that first is building
an id of the building
then there's rooms and
id of the room
behavior of http methods so what to do
when we get http verb depending on
whether that's a collection or object
so basically we've got it's kind of
simple
you just return the collection or the
object of course if the collection is
big
we need to somehow
limit that
with post it's kind of tricky
if you post on a collection that means
hey there's an object i want to put it
in the collection i don't know the idea
of that so just figure it out and let me
know
uh if you do a post on an object it used
to be a partially modification of the
objects but then we have this new method
not that new anymore patch in http so
it's basically no longer
used i think in that context
we've put
logic would dictate that if you put a
collection you just replace the existing
collection but it's again not usually
the case we want we probably want to
just append the collection it's good to
market documentation somehow
and if we do a put
a single object we are replacing it and
here's the question what to do if the
object doesn't exist yet well we can
allow to
put new objects with a given id so doing
put on an object it doesn't exist say
says hey there's an object please put it
under this id i'm providing you
it's a bit tricky because if you let
somebody outside of your system
create ids for your entities you might
be in trouble unless you have some kind
of good validation or just allow
this to be done from internal services
so we have to be careful with that
and delete
pretty simple these entire collection of
course that is
risky so should be controlled
in appropriate manner
and deleting single item this is the
item
and like the newest method patch patch
eye collection
i think doesn't really makes a lot of
sense
but part on a single object
changes a small
say part of it
okay we have behavior now let's move to
function so
we have this noun centric system and
what to do if something a piece appears
to be a function
well
first we can treat it as
patching some other resource for example
there is let's say we bought a ticket
for a train and now we want to cancel it
how to do this where we can patch the
state of the ticket and change its state
to cancel or something but it might not
be always the best idea
uh sometimes invoking a function
is kind of related with creating a
resource so we can here think okay i've
created a constellation object which
also can
have some additional data to it
otherwise
or if you don't have really good idea
how to do this we can just bend the
rules and if it makes sense go with that
don't be too dogmatic all the time
okay
parameters so just quickly reminder on
how to
how can you parameterize requests
you can put something in a path it's not
really exactly a parameter because if we
say cars slash id it's not a parameter
it's just a name of this particular car
if we operate on collection as well
usually we go with queries of everything
after the question mark
that is optional
if you want to separate ourselves from
the let's say business services api we
can go with headers or even deepen with
custom headers
and sometimes it makes sense to send
data in just in the body of the request
one quick note
i encountered the idea that if you if
you use some parameters that are kind of
meta or platform related or very general
they might be
named with underscore at the beginning
and it says be careful with that
so that's something that we can also use
so collections search in a collection
the simplest idea is just
use equal operators so you want people
that are of age 27 so h equals 27 simple
what about if you want someone older or
younger well we can have operator for
that so for example less than greater
than than some kind of delimiter and the
value we are comparing against
we can combine the
property we are comparing against with
with the operator in one single name so
if we are looking for an arnold
we can use name like sword
for example
and okay we found
objects so now how to look into those
objects maybe we are interesting only in
a subset of fields so we can list the
subset of fields on the other hand maybe
object has just one big fit we are not
yet interesting in maybe there is an
outer with large biography and just few
other short fields
then we can just exclude some things and
we can define
several styles of object like small
medium full something like that and let
users deal with that
we found something now it's a good idea
to sort what we found
so we can just specify one property by
which we are sorting with some default
order we can add a prefix or suffix that
determines the order of the searching
of the sorting then we can list
properties then list properties that
should be ascending and those that
should be descending
or we can just for each property we have
a mirror property that selects a
direction of the sort personally i like
this short version with just simple one
character to determine the order of the
sword
next operation on collections
pagination so
normally we use offset and limit for
that number of the page but there's a
problem if someone inserts something or
deletes something while we are iterating
on some
parts of the collection so we can define
cursor that we just point to to one item
and work on that it's not perfect but
it's
somehow
protects us from from getting item twice
or not at all
in case of concurrent changes
there's something between pagination and
sorting that is
defining of some sort parameters uh
search parameter for example let's say
we have ticket system
uh we can define that there is a page
recently clause which has some
kind of sorting in that searching in
that already
another idea besides parameters is using
headers if you want to again
separate yourself from the business
surface of the api
and it's always nice to to include some
links to the next page in the collection
previous page last
or the first
okay status so what happened with with
our request hopefully it was okay but if
not
we can do something with that so first
http codes generally whatever happening
happens on server whether it was
successful or not it should return the
status
the question is how many statuses should
i use
it's a difficult question i believe in
http 1.1 there's around 70 statuses or
so
usually in apis i found between 1 and
20 that's maybe there is a reasonable
maximum
for example facebook always returns
status 200 and then
in the body of the response
actually informs what happened and so do
national railways of switzerland but
they are not the best example of api
design
[Music]
anyway aside from that i think that more
or less 15 codes is to 15 is the
reasonable number of codes we should use
there
what else if something goes wrong
then it's a good idea to say exactly
what happened so first some kind of enum
that says which situation took place it
could be either some name like
payment fraud or something that says
something
or i found an idea of extending http
code so we are adding an additional
digit or two to http code
uh second thing
message so just say what happens for
example if you have
if your clients are developers from
china or some other country maybe then
they don't like english very much you
can for example
i can display this message in different
language forgot the word
and the last but not least what you can
include in such objects is a link to
some kind of faq or documentation
chapter which
explains exactly what happened
and again don't expose internals unless
you are open source of course but
returning stack traces in responses is
not exactly a good idea usually
so briefly on http codes
200
yeah success
201 is used when we create an object
at 202 when we start some kind of
asynchronous processing
and the response is not ready but
we notified that okay we got the
requests we are on it 204 when it when
we delete an object
then we return this
and when we return just a part of the
response and there will be more 206
okay 300 directions kind of tricky 300
is not that not that often used because
there is no really a good standard on
how to handle that it says that there
are multiple choices
301
something was moved per numently so
don't try again on this address
302
it's kind of deprecated because it was
meant as 307 but instead implemented in
the early days as 303 so what are those
307 temporary direct means
the others change temporary and please
use the same method that you did before
so i do a
i post on the server
and if i got 307 it means
redirect and use post again i did
nothing for you on the other hand 300 or
free means
go to another place but use get to
retrieve results so basically i got the
request
i got some processing and i have results
for you and they are somewhere else but
use get to retrieve that
400 i think the most calls are in this
category
unauthorized really means
unauthenticated i don't know who you are
forbidden me three authorized but the
name was already taken it means i know
who you are but you can do this
uh 404 yeah we know that one
row five means the object is there but
the method is not allowed because maybe
it's immutable or for some other reasons
conflict
well the thing that you are trying to do
in the request is in a conflict state
with the server so for example aws s3
would return that if you try to delete a
bucket that has still some files in it
there's a conflict in their definition
gone means that there was a resource but
it is not anymore in in its permanent
situation
and 422
and possible entity is basically kind of
bad request but on a higher
level of abstraction so you would return
but request when the json is for example
my form it lacks one parenthesis
but if you do a request to book a ticket
and
say arrival date is before the departure
date that's a good situation to return
422 so it says that as a business
situation and we can process it
although we understood the request
and server errors so 500 generic error
we don't know what happened we don't
like that
501 is kind of a way saying of saying
that
it's kind of under construction it will
be there try again maybe later in like
in two weeks or something
um
but gateway and gate gateway timeout are
somehow similar and it's saying that
when we were acting as a gateway
something bad happened with someone else
so either another service screwed
screwed the response or didn't respond
at all sorry there is nothing i could do
and it's okay if we are talking internal
apis and microservices then we just go
to another team and ask hey what's going
on but on the other hand if if i'm an
external client i don't really care
which one service screw up something
i'm interested i'm interested in what
happened basically so
it's not very recommended to to use as
status code in external api i think
and service on available is a way of
saying that hey we are down but there is
some maintenance everything will be okay
instead of just 500 it's not working
so that's the main let's say
business part now let's go to this
quickly to the supporting thing
uh so
a few words about security about
versioning cash and performance
throttling
haters and then some
less technical things but also some
miscellaneous if you don't know where to
put something you can always put it in
miscellaneous category
security
well
2019 you should use tsl whenever
possible and https
if someone goes to our endpoint without
https we shouldn't redirect them to
https just return errors so that
situation is clear
cryptography is difficult so
even if you have phd in cryptography and
10 years of experience is probably not
the best idea to invent our own ciphers
and
cryptographic schemes especially
security by obscurity is a bad idea
instead of
passwords and username is good to use
api cases
keys as they have
they are more secure it's difficult to
guess them
and there is probably
everyone
or almost everyone knows the old wsap
opponent application security projects
but if you don't just check this out dot
org it's a list of 10 most important
threats in web application and it's
always always
good to see what is
currently on top there
okay
versioning so our api changes and how to
deal with that
the most popular and usual solution is
just to embed version in the url
so we say photo is api version two
of our one or without anything is
version one on the other hand we can go
a bit deeper
and use parameter for that so that way
for example if someone does not include
this parameter so it's optional you can
assume that we are returning the newest
version of the api
again if we want to
go away from the business surface of the
api we can use headers either accept
header for that or we can use our own
headers
and
api versioning and resource versioning
are two different things so we can have
new api all the api
and return new version of resource and
old version of resource
you shouldn't be confused
cache control
cache is difficult but in general what
we can do about this
we have this
values of cache control headers
basically public and private is about
whether the information is
meant for single use just single users
or is publicly available so if there is
a logo of the web page
it can be marked as public if there is
some particular data for the user it
probably should be private
those should be public and this will be
private
um if we can allow resource to be stale
we don't care about
it's to be very fresh then we specify
some kind of max save so how stale it
should be
no cache doesn't really mean that we
don't have any benefits from caching it
just means that
the resource should be always fresh so
whatever
the client checks for the resource in
proxy we need to check on the server and
if the results didn't change well we are
in luck we can just return the value
from the proxy if not we need to refresh
that
on the other hand no store
says that we can't use caching at all
basically it's about sensitive data like
medical records or anything related with
money usually
and we don't want to store even of on
the device of the user or maybe
especially on the device of the user
so how to
uh how to deal with all those values
there are actually like 15 or so more
basically we need to think if the data
is private or public if it can be if it
can be stale or not and if it is
sensitive and then we can
set some effective caching strategy so
that we save both
on bandwidth and performance and
computing power of our systems and
clients
throttling so how to deal with
many requests
basically you can just return 500 server
kaput
but we can do better
for example
there are three headers not standard but
commonly used that say that
there's a limit in time window
how many requests are left in current
time window and when the time new time
window starts
and if the client is in no luck and
there is no more requests in the time
window then you can return 400 429 to my
request and the information that let's
say hey
there will be new opening in seven
seconds so just try again then and not
try every second because it won't work
anyway and again we save on both on our
site and client side
hey toast
who of you did play diablo 2
yeah lots of guys
so it's lord of hate mephisto it kind of
went well with this slide haters so
hyper media as the engine of application
states the most beautiful
acronym for in our industry the idea is
that we
with the response we return links to
related resources and what we can do
about this resource
around this resource so that way
a client doesn't have to remember all
those links and follow the versioning
you can just take the link that we
return and and follow that
and there are several there's no really
one standard of how to do this there are
several personally i used hull it worked
pretty well for me there is also
collection plus json which is kind of
originating in collections but
works pretty well with links too
there is json link document which is
kind of good if you don't want to break
backward compatibility so like
encapsulate the requests in another
object and there is siren which is i
think quite powerful but not that
popular
documentation so
moving a bit away from the technical
side
um documentation should be
easy to find and ideally public so i
don't have to mail the support and wait
two weeks to get the documentation there
are
three tiers of kinds of documentation
there is like this address book which is
exhaustive reference
everything we can do with the api but
really boring
then there is
engaging tutorial which is kind of a
business story we start with something
we do some other requests we complete
something
and we can follow that and there is an
engaging
that was engaging so how does console
quickstart there's something that we put
on the front page of our product so the
developer can just take it
and start from that
and move efficiently
miscellaneous
so as i said about those
six principles of good product design
and
people with disabilities so if i'm a
person with disability and i can't do a
post request because of my proxy then i
can use a header for that x http method
override
and just specify the value of the method
i really want to use while i'm using get
method
it's kind of maybe obsolete because most
modern
web browsers do this but we can add a
parameter to pretty pin json so
automatically insert indentation and new
lines so it's more readable
in process that do not support this for
encoding we have standard header so
let's invent our
own solutions
uh it's just ued
when we are creating new resources it's
not the best idea to just
go with consecutive numbers one two
three and four because then
somebody can just ask for all the all
the numbers and get all the data from
our database and aside from losing data
we are losing quite a lot of performance
here so it's
it's good to use some longer and random
id so it's difficult to guess them
and somewhat similar request uids
sometimes called correlation ids
if you start
let's say the processing flow on the
boundary of our system then some calls
are fired to microservices maybe there
are quite a lot of them we can add a
parameter with this id of the request
and then it's easy to find this
in logs and debug the situation
um
rest clients
and browsers there are some api vendors
who have an idea that if somebody access
api from
web browser it means we want to return
html instead of json it's generally a
bad idea we have content negotiation for
that
we have standards for time so let's not
invent our own standards for that
[Music]
health endpoints it's more about
internal apis not external
but aside from the health endpoint that
we need for for example our kubernetes
or some other automation to to see if
our service is okay
so it's a good idea to add more
information for developer for example
the git version from which the service
was built or the values of some
important properties
or some other stuff
so we can it can be a bit enriched
and
last but not least external apis
there are often product projects in the
company which has this b2c business to
client model and many front-end to add
an external api and connect with big
business and it usually sounds quite
good and easy you just make some kind of
gateway separate service do some
configuration and security a few other
things it will be nice but in practice
it turns out that those projects are
actually just a bit about new technology
and in
quite
large part in dealing with
uh
existing problems in our systems meaning
if we if if we if you want to create
external api we have to think
what should be exposing that because
often internal apis we expose a lot of
things
that are not very secure to expose so
now we have to limit that
often there is a situation where a
business flow of our system is not
really
prepared for b2b for example you have a
flaws to pay with credit cards or
braintree paypal or whatever but you
don't have an option to issue an invoice
and you have to add that to make it work
or on the other hand
it's often common that you have to do a
little small modifications in many parts
of the system for example remember last
time when i was taking part in
similar project
i think it was the moment when i checked
out the
um the largest number of git
repositories in this company because we
had to add a small field partner id in
very many places
so when you hear that there is an
external api
under construction beware it might
it might mean that there is a lot of
dirty work to be done but on the other
hand
that's an opportunity to get to know the
system better because you work on many
places and like get this
good overview so how how the client
would see it from the outside
and
another aspect is that often there is no
good consensus of the naming of part of
the system for example when we did this
api for travel it turns out that one
micro service returns something by the
name of segment another service calls
this itinerary
another service calls this lag and now
we suddenly have to somehow unify that
and
and it should make sense from the
business point of view
to sum up
good api takes a lot of effort a lot of
things we need to think about
especially some of them are not that
visible from the
from the business side
api is percy's a product for developers
thinking as a developer might be kind of
tricky for business people
but
api to developer is more like
graphical user interface is to regular
user
so we need to keep that in mind
if you are going with rest because it's
not the only way for example you can
choose graphql
yesterday there was a nice talk about
graphql literally one attempt maybe yeah
there are many many alternatives there
are binary protocols
but the if you are talking about rest
verbs are the
center of rest
uh we need to take advantage of http
semantics so methods
headers status all that good stuff
and look at those principles but do not
follow it blindly because something
sometimes something doesn't really fit
into the
into into the picture but it's
i mean doesn't fit into the rest picture
but still makes sense and we can just
bend the rules if we know what we are
doing
okay if you fall asleep or just come
later to this lecture
most of what i said and quite a lot more
is in i think six or seven currently
articles on my blog
it's how to train your java just like
the movie but with java instead of
dragon
so welcome to drop by
okay
questions
yes
i'm not sure actually
but
uh i think this is one of the common
functionalities that is actually
implemented but by api management
platforms like
apg or however it is now called because
it was about bought by google wso2
or
aws gateway
i think in all of them i saw
the point about frotlink so i suppose
they do
any other questions
yeah
you didn't mention anything about
parameters inside the body
that we are using it that we are
actually picking in external rp
i'm often seeing that people
use a trade to use request response as a
part of naming and to me it's
[Music]
well i saw the problem that somebody
needed to request
a long
list of
and the question basically about
parameters in eureka's body
if they are good or not
the problem was that somebody
has a situation that he wanted to
request a very very very long list of
resources and the list was particularly
that long that it may not fit the the
length of the url
and
he was wondering that maybe then it is a
good idea to put it in a body
actually i mean
when i'm looking for a sweater yes i'm
often seeing
the description of posts
that
people describing elements yes
as for example
peoples yes and they
hold the request people request and
define the body and responds people
respond
and defines the body of response
it's not looking like resource-oriented
style
but very often
i see the style of defining
documentation
and i didn't find any
good place describing
how
this app should like and how we should
describe this requested response
[Music]
i'm not very
sure how to answer that
i don't gotta think about it
uh another questions
i don't want to stand between you and
beer for too long so maybe if there are
other questions just catch me later
today or tomorrow and that will be all
thank you